after a dangerous journey these refugees
from de batsilva have finally reached a
safe haven
they're at a train station in the city
of kharkiv they have to fill out
paperwork
27 year old valerie arrived last friday
the ordeal has left him very shaken
my sister is still in
she has three kids she can't leave she
has cows a car furniture at home
even though the garage has already been
destroyed she won't leave she's afraid
to leave home with her kids
he's planning to go stay with friends in
the west of ukraine away from the
fighting but many here don't have that
option
i'm also from dubai
i don't know what to do
i arrived without any clothes shoes or
money what should we do please help us
we don't have a flat everything was
destroyed
the ukrainian army recently lost control
of the nearby town of vulgarsk after
heavy fighting now ukrainian officials
are struggling to complete a civilian
evacuation of the area
and to offer beds for the refugees
on the outskirts of kharkiv a polish aid
agency has set up emergency
accommodation
irena malieva was brought to the
settlement on the outskirts of town by
friends from
kharkiv were lucky we left so early in
the morning it was quiet and there was
little shooting
that's how we got out safely
she didn't wait for any official
evacuation before deciding to drive to
kharkiv when she arrived at the camp
there were barely any places left
the fighting is leaving large numbers of
people displaced many have nowhere to
turn